Oprah Winfrey she has a new show on own  yay called Queen sugar and she is  teaming up with a claim director Ava  Duvernay and we were the first to talk  to them that shows special premiere  she's something Oprah showing Ava some  love on the red carpet their new drama  is set on an 800-acre Louisiana  sugarcane farm where three estranged  siblings have reunited after a family  tragedy this is good land  just knees tender the new trailer is out  and is nothing short of cinematic Ava  directed the to 9 premiere a blazed a  trail with the decision to form an  all-female directorial team for  inclusiveness let's do something that's  never been done before that woman's  voice and that point of view is  something that I had to have the best  part though being inducted into Oprah  squad everyone knows of her warmth and  her generosity through the Oprah show I  feel like I get my own Oprah show  whenever I call her